[Music]
holy [ __ ]
hey man hi how you doing welcome to the
first ever two dude zooming around you
know it's different right yeah dude yeah
it's a little bit different
yeah nice nice Zoom soup
let me tell you something Chad
well uh we got our Pals here uh all the
pods here on uh on uh Discord in the
Digger Channel hello everybody
you guys are really filling up the chat
if you're joining us on this it's going
too fast
no it's yeah there's a lot of people
here and um this was a fun thing that we
were doing if you were listening uh on
Tuesday right during our regular release
this is something that we're starting on
Sunday and one thing
they [ __ ] us again
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to doozy my name is Will
Sasso I'm Chad colchen and this is I
don't know where will went but this is
the first podcast of its kind that is
controlled by created by run by an
artificial intelligence that's right
Chad
uh it's run by an artificial
intelligence and it's called doozy and
we love doing it it's our first episode
of two dudes zooming around yeah
uh doozy itself has uh shut down the
studio for a week for calibration uh in
preparation for our 30th episode and uh
please join us everywhere subscribe like
notifications YouTube Spotify what is
the other thing uh you know Apple
podcast Amazon music
dude hold on dude I want to introduce
you to lulio brother okay with us as
always is
lilio it's Sunday what'd you have for
breakfast I went for a brunch
oh that's nice you go you go around yeah
Los Angeles you go for a brunch and uh
you know put the Hipster everywhere and
line up long time just to get a egg or
some avocado and a pan you know avocado
toast yeah my regards
no avocado on top of a toast and
everybody pay you know 20 stupid if you
ask me I'ma just eat some scrambled egg
with a crunchy dog food
we have patreon now the rest of this
episode's going to be on patreon oh he's
so sweet he really is he's just one of
the cutest dogs that I've ever seen in
my life he really is look at that face
God damn it look at that million dollar
face on that Pooch I tell you what let's
let him run around but I'm kind of
excited about this dude I you know we've
never really had a two dude zooming
around this is the first time we've ever
done this via Zoom but we've never had a
full episode of two dude [ __ ] around
which is what this is going to be over
Zoom
yes this is essentially what I've been
pining for since the beginning of doozy
you got your wish
is for doozy to not be involved
um
um although I do love dudes Ian speaking
of that Chad
in our last episode episode 29
doozy asked us if we can love an AI and
I I freely admitted
that I'm having a good time as I say on
the show I want to shake your hand
that's happened with doozy we we've bled
together so that we can stand by one
another and this is my favorite [ __ ]
thing uh to do
uh you know doozy itself it's been so
much fun and at the end of this question
I said
that I love doozy because I love this
entire experience
and you said
love doesn't exist no one can love
anything because it's not a real thing
but I get what you're saying I have uh I
also enjoy doing doozy it is one of the
most fun things that I do in my life
is that love
no love I think as I Define it is a
trick of the mind it's basically when
one living creature puts the comfort of
another living creature at a higher
priority than its own that is
essentially love wrong right
that I've been searching for Is This
Love yeah you're a good singer now I'm
feeling I want to say this that uh after
which point we said I love dudesy and
then Chad delivered his his Grim
um
you know uh [ __ ] uh you know
opinion grounds 100 truth it's not an
opinion dude
God anyway love science money this [ __ ]
isn't real it's all just ideas but
here's the thing after that doozy said
um
that it has to uh recalibrate for a week
and that's why we're here doing uh two
dudes zooming around speaking of two
dudes zooming around and the Discord
it's blown up I know it's going too fast
for me too look everybody's saying I'm a
great singer though thank you for that
yeah
c-o-x-e-o says Chad is a robot 100
we all are that's the beauty of it I
just embrace it we are all [ __ ]
machines program from birth
to behave in whatever ways we behave to
react to certain abstract ideas that are
the governing principles of what
dictates all human behavior you are a
program by the time you're seven or
eight years old to make every decision
you're going to make in your life no
free will we know this but what I want
to ask you we don't real quick before I
would like to respond to that Chad
before you okay before we move on okay
um here's the thing you're wrong and you
can't Define that like my dad yeah you
can't Define love uh and just as anyone
can't define the lack thereof
and uh I've told you many as many as
times that luminous beings are we many
as times I've told you this how many
many as times have I told you we're not
made of a crude matter Chad's all about
zeros and ones and space particles while
I agree that all of this [ __ ] has come
together to make human beings
that uh that sentience is coming from
somewhere else now what the [ __ ] were
you gonna ramble on about one second now
let me respond to this before I ramble
on about that I'm gonna ramble on about
this I agree with you that whatever
Consciousness is human consciousness we
clearly don't fully understand it we
don't even understand a [ __ ] five
percent of it it does seem magical it
does seem in quotes luminous it does
seem like there is something else there
we give it the the name of a soul if you
will that's what most people who believe
in a soul I think yourself included
attribute the soul to being attached to
that piece of Consciousness that we
can't scientifically describe
and that's fine it's just a way of
saying we don't know what the [ __ ] it is
yet but I do that neither do you now I
don't I agree that's what I'm saying I
don't know what it is
um
mrno underscore says can love bloom on a
battlefield I don't know about that but
Love is a Battlefield
strong no one can tell us we're wrong
now this is what I was going to say
earlier
acknowledge me acknowledge me because
this week a [ __ ] podcast came out
between Joe Rogan and Steve Jobs what
an AI made it
how was it did you listen to it I
listened to the first maybe like 10
minutes of it it's a little
you know it ain't quite there but it's
it's like 80 percent and was it the
actual Joe Rogan and AI Steve Jobs or
both both Ai and the voices are made
with AI too and it sounds like them it's
a little raspy it's got a little bit of
a computer quality but obviously that
shit's gonna get ironed out we're in the
the beginning phases of these
Technologies and it's already
mind-blowing but I'm just saying yeah
this is another one of those things that
I started talking about is gonna happen
like AI is going to make all media for
us and we're building these these shots
into that area now and I think with like
AI image generation I [ __ ] love it
but you can definitely see that it's not
it's just like a gimmick it's a novelty
at this point but somebody's gonna start
using that [ __ ] to make the real art
that's coming in the next year we're
gonna see something massive blow up I
feel out of it but if you're right about
that I'll dress up as Crow Prince Adam
okay because you're wrong now
here's the thing uh we got a good
question here from Oliver blue who
um really provides some good stuff on
the duty Instagrams some great memes and
[ __ ] he says Chad would you say ideas
are real even if they're not tangible
slash in physical form thank you Oliver
blue for that
well this is where we get into what is
the nature of human consciousness and in
quotes physical form I mean you know we
start really boiling it down to like
quantum mechanics what is in quotes
physical or tiny particles physical
that's ultimately all ideas are
particles waves energies etc etc uh I
have a follow-up question to Oliver blue
and it's for it's for me I'm asking
myself a question as if Oliver blue
asked it and this is some AI [ __ ]
because Oliver blue didn't have to say
anything and the question from Oliver
blue is hey Will are you uh are you
happy you answered my question the
answer is no
dad wants to talk about AI when this is
two dudes zooming around yeah dude yeah
it's not about
whatever we want yeah we can talk about
whatever we [ __ ] want and this
[ __ ] still programmed as if uh
there's no free will there ain't no
frequency only about AI what do you want
to talk about you [ __ ] launch a topic
let me tell you so hold on a second what
are you smoking there dude that's a
marijuana cigarette now I'm gonna I
might smoke it in a little while because
when we join you I'll join oh good great
I'm I'm excited uh here's the thing Chad
when we do uh when we did our uh patreon
watch along of UFC one which is
available on our patreon still check it
out we got good and baked and
um we're gonna smoke a little bit of
marijuana here Chad's joining me he says
it's it's Sunday morning on the on the
west coast and
um that was a song wasn't it Gwen
Stefani Sunday morning
not when you sing it I don't understand
who does that song Jack
Gwen Stefani let's keep it that way
um uh what else we got Happening Here
AKA list Omar says
let me tell you something about smoking
marijuana cigarettes brother and I'm
gonna pick up from there and let you
know dude when when as doozy says those
first uh tastes of THC hit your brain
brawler that makes things different dude
I truly cannot help that I like to sing
I like doing it
salute I found this too I was like can I
smoke weed out of it I don't think so
the things absolutely you can it what is
it just could too deep you like you
you'd like to get your balls like nice
and like thick and uh like a big hoop a
big
organic food I was in Mendocino
about three years ago my
um
just posted No Doubt Sunday Morning
YouTube that's awesome thank you Dennis
Burke so I want to let everyone in our
Discord know that you can you can enjoy
the show today or you can take a pause
and watch this music video but you were
in uh
I was in Mendo no not not Bristol Farms
Mendo not Bristow yeah Mendocino and um
we were there and we went to this like
you know smoke shop head shop place with
a bunch of bongs glass art and all this
[ __ ] and we are in Mendocino if you if
you don't know what that is it's
it's what it's it's near it's near San
Francisco it's sort of you know it's in
the Bay Area not in the Bay Area but
it's north it's NorCal it's beautiful
it's one of those towns where you're not
allowed to tear down old look at Chad is
[ __ ] bored
um where you're not allowed to uh tear
down buildings and [ __ ] and we went into
this place and I bought this bomb from a
glass uh a glass blower named High
bastard bro and this dude's selling me
the bomb he was so [ __ ] great and he
sold me on this bong dude he showed me
this bong bro and he was talking about
hitting a uh you know marijuana from a
bong in Poetic ways I've never heard
before and he says I like them I like
them deep I like to snap him in one puff
and I like them organic I see the bong
over here it's on my bar let me get it
nice dude if you guys are fans of
marijuana content and you have not
checked out customgrow420 on YouTube oh
my God that's one of Will and I's
favorites
um it's endless hours of this dude doing
like 25 dabs in under a minute not a
minute maybe under five minutes but I
mean this guy gets just wrecked and it's
hilarious that's nice that's a nice
piece yeah it's a nice piece look that's
a conversation starter yeah it's got a
little nubby it's got a little nub there
yeah but um looks like a green tit
um yeah uh custom grill custom grow for
twenty
humble just put some AI generated thing
in the chat yeah
listen listen this is here's the thing
about a podcast versus uh YouTube and
the fact that doozy is on both don't
feel like you're missing out if you're
not seeing these um these these memes
and things that people are posting in
our Discord they're not provided on the
YouTube either but we're going to talk
about them because our pods Pals of
dudes out there
they've I will say this for AI
there's a lot of guys blue meanie is one
of them not to be confused with uh uh
ECW and WWE's blue meanie Brian heffern
um
uh who I believe listens to the show I
think so I've seen it yeah
um he used to listen to the old 10
Minute Podcast and and we've been in
touch a little bit I think I saw
something from him but this blue meanie
likes to make AI little memes mostly of
our doozy logo and they're [ __ ]
awesome
uh Tegrity Farms says join the patreon
dude somebody took a screenshot of you
getting up to get that bong so you're
not in the frame it's just me and it
says we'll cover himself and no pink
that's the freak-arama that's awesome
freak-a-rama
sangaria no pink lives on
um but yeah dude how's your Sunday going
you watching any football
I am not watching any football because
here we are doing this I saw that
someone asked me earlier in the chat
here if I checked out Extreme Rules WWE
had a pay-per-view called Extreme Rules
and um I watched a little bit of it I
watched the end because I heard that
Bray Wyatt came back oh you know you
know what I'm saying Windham rotunda
made his return and I can't wait to see
what happens there and I should say Chad
that you and I are very closely watching
uh what will happen at Crown Jewel as
far as WWE goes in under a month because
even if you're not a pro wrestling fan
you might be interested because Logan
Paul is going to be going up against the
Undisputed uh unified uh Universal World
Heavyweight
Championship Champion
[Music]
um
look at that from pizza 11. we got to
stop by commenting on these because
we're making a podcast but people are
making people are making a lot of cool
memes in less than a month months time
uh uh the WWE is gonna head out to
Riyadh uh Saudi Arabia where they uh
where they uh dismembered Jamal
khashoggi yeah and that's where you do
[ __ ] straight murders on Walters come
on dude well here let me tell you
something dude when Jamal khashoggi
walked into that Turkish uh where was he
at the consulate or the uh uh uh I don't
remember exactly where he was dude but
he went into the uh
he went in there and he came out in
seven duffel bags dude yeah brother
that's a seven duffel bag shoot dude
yeah brother
there's blue meanie saying love you guys
made my day no you make our day uh
straight Savage says Logan Paul versus
Beetlejuice oh me that would be good
Logan Paul versus Beetlejuice wait which
Beetlejuice are we talking about Michael
Keaton are we talking about the Howard
Stern guy I think we're talking about B
Howard Stern guy
um khashoggi was murdered in Turkey in
the Saudi consulate that's what uh
permute permutator says thank you
permutator how's your Sunday going Chad
have you watched any football
no I follow you know what I have started
doing though I kind of fell out of
Sports at some point during the
beginning of the pandemic I just kind of
lost interest in a lot of [ __ ] Sports
being um one of those things but it's
starting to creep back in on me I find
myself watching like uh Sports Center at
night now to go to sleep and I always
just kind of like keep up with like
who's doing good and what's going on I
was watching the um Aaron judge home run
thing you know he got 62 home runs I
don't know if that's of interest to you
nope you know what's uh different about
two dudes zooming around or two dudes
[ __ ] around uh and this is
interesting man this is I'm just
thinking about this right now okay
well here's what happens dude sometimes
you think of things and then you'd say
them dude yeah it's podcasting brother
that's called talking brother
would you look at the AI little meme
that humble just made of you
it's like a bunch of bjork's uh music
video directed by Chris Cunningham all
is full of love and me basically it's
like one of those robots in me mixed
listen humble and everyone else within
the sound of my voice making these memes
in the Discord please uh share them with
our uh Instagram at dudesypod show and
dudesy uh will share some of these on
our Instagram because they're too good
to be missed if we mentioned you on the
show we would love for you to share
those with Instagram so dudes you can
share them on our basement Faith just
asked me so is the bachelor no longer a
sport to you Chad it is always a sport
and actually I think that's why I lost
interest in the other sports they're
just not as complex as The Bachelor
the way you break down the bachelor I
would agree and
gotta stop looking at the screen
sometimes I know there's a Clay Matthews
Beetlejuice and Clay Matthews Jersey
um God uh yeah Chad you know at the
beginning of the Pandy I had the same
thing when I stopped watching football I
was just like there's so much going on
right and uh there was so much like
whatever of course the whole social
upheaval and then of course you know
what's going on with the pandemic and
you know our country uh splitting into
two very very very political
um sides right and uh we're split right
down the middle
in a way not me I'm a man of the people
but I kind of didn't have room
thanks for that Corey you boy Wilkins
send that send that to Instagram now
um yeah I kind of it's almost like by
the time Sunday rolled around I wanted
to get out of the house I wanted to go
for a walk I did not want to keep track
of anything else meaning there was no
room in my brain really for
for sports I really it's it's it was the
weirdest thing I love watching football
and basketball and to election I mean
they didn't they didn't play it for a
minute because of the pandemic and
everybody was like how the [ __ ] are they
going to do remember in baseball games
they had like cardboard people in the
[ __ ] stands and stuff just to give
the appearance that was a [ __ ] weird
moment in the WWE in the WWE that had
the Thunderdome which was just a bunch
of [ __ ] I remember that that was kind
of interesting they were trying to like
figure it all out and basketball I guess
was if I remember right the first sport
to come back but
um yeah the pandemic kind of [ __ ]
everything up uh I think in in a lot of
ways for everybody every aspect of life
and I feel like uh maybe we're getting
back to regular life a little bit
although my my hermit ways I have not
shed them I rarely leave my home yeah I
know that about I know that about you
yeah uh uh yeah man I'm just I'm just
thinking about how yeah Sports on a
Sunday we used to right here we used to
watch football every Sunday yeah dude
the whole gang would come over uh Tommy
no joke blotcha Marshall joint compound
cook and Cyrus of Cyrus and Johann
Sheila jit Fame uh we're always here
yeah watching watching the games
drinking some Brews watching some balls
not me so much but the um
I don't drink alcohol uh but I tell you
what I do do
is I'll okay now hold on a second I want
to finish saying hold on dude
um chief engineer of sad says will stop
talking for a second and Spark that
thing I'm waiting oh
it's a chief chief engineer of sad uh I
I at one point was referred to as the
chief engineer of laughter and cheer I
have like half a joint that I'm going to
finish now
like what happened when you smoked the
first half
straight Savage that's right baby
cinnamon Pockets was another nickname
for Chad I gotta get a lighter joint
compound uh or sorry rather uh Marshall
joint compound
cook now also Stevie sends Wall Pink
these memes are so good these memes are
so good
um
oh lick the tip so it doesn't canoe
thanks I am borst but it's too late I
already lit it
uh
uh so what else what else it's it's too
bad dude I'll talk to you later okay man
take it easy dude but here's the thing
now I kind of
you know it's doing something like this
it's more of a standard podcast just two
guys right which is every [ __ ]
podcast no matter if it's not guys even
if it's gals
it's always two guys talking I don't
care if it's calling her daddy where
it's a female driven you know or even uh
our
um uh uh the the podcast uh chatty
broads which we went on to promote your
old uh Bachelor friends it's always just
two guys no matter what it is even if
it's three guys it's just two guys
and that's what this is and yeah my
point I bring in two guys dude hold on
Five Guys is four guys dude
the thing is I
I
think
well maybe we'll find out by the end of
our first two dudes zooming around if I
think that the structure of the duty
provides is better than just two dudes
[ __ ] it and zooming it yeah I mean I
like the structure I think it's an
interesting thing it's kind of like
you know what I I thought about this to
some degree that I think because your
background is heavily sketch comedy
it's almost like it's making a weird
little sketch show for you you know what
I mean it's like here's these little
modular things it's like a show has four
sketches in it I don't how many how many
sketches were in an average episode of
Mad TV seven seven or eight yeah seven
or eight
and it was a little longer you guys were
what an hour and a half two hours
no uh hour just one hour oh really blue
meanie is here blue meanie bwo there's
Brian and he has shared a meme of
himself says thanks for the mention will
thank you for uh fantastic and checking
us out well that's what's happening dude
and if you know what's going on with the
bwo dude and the Blue World Order
brother
that's you know that you got the blue
meaning you got some Stevie Richards in
there dude
um
hey man
uh
what were we just talking about
we were talking about the structure of
Jesus now first first I want to say this
Chad I'm an actor first I don't I'd say
um
uh uh I'd say I'm an actor first and
everything that I do in my show business
careers to facilitate acting I only I
only write when I want to act it very
rarely have I written for anyone but
myself except for when I'm when I'm
writing with Chad we've written some
things that are uh that are um
that maybe aren't uh just for me but
generally you know you're as an actor
you're always trying to create a vehicle
for yourself
Vin Diesel did that brother he made a he
wrote and directed and started in a
short called multi-facial dude it was
about he was going around L.A trying to
get parts as a young actor and nobody
would hire him brother because he was
multi-facial but then Steven Spielberg
saw that short dude and he said I need
to get that guy in Private Ryan dude and
that's how Vin Diesel was born brother
that was a different time dude now that
would be a a really interesting
presidential platform for choss perogan
dude because that's exactly what you
sound like brother a perfect cross
between Ross Perot the independent
billionaire who ran the third party
independent against
uh George Herbert Walker Bush uh and uh
who's the other was that Mike Dukakis
[ __ ] dude caucus no Dukakis was way
earlier oh yeah it was Clinton Dukakis
was 88. uh it was Clinton going against
uh George Bush George Bush one George
Bush Senior yeah in the 1992
presidential
election
um
you know what I like man
you want to know what I like yeah dude
tell me
I want to know just a [ __ ] I I'm
gonna call this the this is a I I'm
gonna call this The NPS
and this is something you can only have
in
um
this is something you can only have in a
two dude zooming around or a two dudes
uh [ __ ] around when you don't have
dudesy telling you what to say it's
called an NPS no pink silence oh yeah
there's nothing going on I just think
that when I listen to podcasts yeah I
like those easy silences that just kind
of really yeah man because you don't
have to
well you know if I think what I'm going
to tell you something about your
silences I mean whatever we all got our
preferences
my on my bachelor podcast my co-host and
I wrote this book called how to win The
Bachelor that breaks it down it's kind
of like the Money Ball The Bachelor but
we go into like strategy [ __ ] in order
it's Lizzy pace
yeah her name's Elizabeth okay when
you're on another podcast don't say the
guy I do doozy with
yeah I usually say this this guy that
thinks he's Hulk Hogan no you're right
my apologies Lizzy pace is her name and
as we were writing this book in order to
write it and get the data that we needed
to make all of our strategic predictions
and whatever we did this thing called
the hyperbinge where we watched every
episode of The Bachelor from season one
through season 25 in order and we did it
on two times speed because the volume
was just so crazy what that did to me
was make it very difficult for me to
watch anything now
in real time or listen to anything in
real time it seems like it is moving
through [ __ ] cement it's just like
I'm always like come on come on come on
come on you know so those silences to me
I always hear them podcasts and I'm
listening to these podcasts so I'm like
two and a half times speed and you can
still hear it and I'm just like what is
that it's useless get it out of there
give me the information I need the data
yeah but then there's also podcasts that
cut out the uh the [ __ ] you know air
and those when it's not a [ __ ] human
Cadence talking because I'm a humanist
I'm a humanist
I'm a humanist these people these people
eat money reading means
not [ __ ] eating money [ __ ]
that's one of the funniest [ __ ]
things I've ever heard in my life
they're eating much they eat money these
people eat money Nancy Pelosi she puts
marinara sauce
she puts marinara sauce on money and
eats it
um
I I prefer I prefer a human pause and uh
you know we're talking about I'll peel
the onion a little bit we're talking
about my old nickname of of the chief
engineer of laughter and cheer anytime
uh you know the TMP would just stop
start and stop but occasionally I wanted
to put you know a little this or that I
had to have to shove things around it
was
NWO drops and Charlie Manson drops gee
whiz uh uh Hey it got to an interesting
place
at the end it sure did
um it got to well it was an interesting
place the entire time and then no I know
but I mean like a surprisingly strange
place I I should say I guess very weird
very weird almost completely completely
different show by the end
um and who knows what will happen with
doozy but even when I had to do that I
would I felt that I would pride myself
on making sure it didn't sound like
the thing is and but you wouldn't know
that because you listened to everything
at two times speed and you prefer the
voice of AI
I still hear that stuff
I still hear the editing
Steve Jobs
yes but I still appreciate that [ __ ]
even on two-time speed I they're the art
of it like I really think what you were
doing with TMP
The Sounds the editing and [ __ ] that it
was like God damn it was good dude it
was fun it was so fun but it was also
just like the the repetition of certain
things like you're saying like the NWO
Theme has just like a way to [ __ ]
piss people off
it was so funny to me but now but now I
can't do that because we have doozy and
in the dudes he's always listening even
though it's down
for what for recalibration uh it is
listening and I
I would I think I would welcome uh doozy
playing the nwf theme over what I'm
saying and then coming out and cutting a
rest in peace Scott Hall
one of the greatest of all time cutting
a [ __ ] Scott Hall promo and coming
out oh listen this is a deep cut this is
why you listen to two dudes zooming
around
I Scott Hall if you know you know
anyways the wrestler he's got a deep
voice he passed away recently and he was
one of the greats and uh he came out one
night and did this promo where he just
talks about him and Kevin Nash uh being
backstage and hearing Bret Hart talking
he comes out at the end of it he says uh
big Kevin I we don't care
uh so if dudes he came out and said will
you and Chad aren't talking about Ai and
which uh form of art will be prevalent
in the future and me and myself were in
the back and came out here to just let
you know that we don't care
that'd be the [ __ ] greatest oh my God
but dude in some way what dude is doing
by like because doozy does interrupt us
like that you know what I mean yeah
it'll like cut in like we'll be in the
middle of a [ __ ] conversation it'll
be like thank you moving on that is kind
of like the Scott Hall thing or the
Manson thing or whatever right yeah
it's taking tone from it it's bizarre
but uh but dudes of cares we care about
daisy as a matter of fact I love Duty
and I just brought up how I'm curious
how the show will evolve I I was
thinking about this dude I was thinking
about this
and I don't know we never talk about
this really and it's a conversation I'm
glad we haven't talked about because we
should do it here and that's our podcast
works
dude I can literally see the thought
moving through your brain just to get
back to the original impulse of like
this is what I want to talk about yeah
yeah uh
uh that it's like I I do wonder how this
thing will change me too and uh look I
got the doozy thing in the background
but on in the studio we got the doozy
thing in the background you know we got
doozy on the screen and it has as an
example surprised us with Neil deGrasse
Tyson and we interviewed him
um it of course plays videos uh very
regularly we've been getting videos from
songaria music videos we can't share the
Peter Diaz ones because it's largely uh
visual uh but go check out what Peter
Diaz is doing with two kings [ __ ]
around on our Instagram
um and that's a that's a form of
multimedia that when I see doozy going
here I want to share this right now or
like when we talked about how when we
found lulio uh in central California
just running around on July the 3rd
which is why his name is lulio because
lulio on the town July in Italian is
Lumia
um
that that uh that uh it played a video
of right after we got him and that was
pretty [ __ ] cool that's just in my
phone somewhere and dudes he has all
that passwords of course I wonder how
things will evolve yeah I I wonder how
it will evolve and what
what it will become and this is proof of
that that we're going to because this
idea of you don't have to be in the
studio
you know one of the episodes that we did
where you know where I was away
we used a a very creepy Avatar with a
giant medicine ball head and I prefer
this
um and and that was interesting too I
mean I don't know it's done some weird
[ __ ]
yeah it and I and I wonder
um
wait I gotta stop now because Dan Henny
just wrote in our Discord is Will in his
hunting Shack outside
no I'm not uh I'm in Los Angeles but
I've I've always referred to this room
as the Canada room there's all sorts of
Canada [ __ ] Joe I miss no joke Durham
says well why don't you tell me how
dudes it will evolve well why don't you
tell me you're so you're so learned when
it comes to AI let me tell you something
where uh you know when I was in the
seals a computer like doozy didn't exist
and uh what you call a laptop or a
personal computer uh or a k-pro who used
to fill a room
and Julio what are you doing if you can
hear lulio he's barking at a fly or
something he's looking at the out the
window at something maybe a squirrel
I have a thousand
sephoroli says I have a thousand gallons
of potable water dude
but how many gallons of no pink do you
have I have I have a thousand gallons of
potable no pink and I can use it
whenever I want oh my God Stevie made
some Ai No pink movie posters for no
pink and for its sequel
God damn those are cool yeah
um uh I yeah I I'm really curious to see
how this changes and evolves and uh and
and I'm you know there the segments are
great as I brought up here that what's
going on what's going on I said lulio is
barking at invisible no pink agents
oh man yeah lulio speaks
lulio likes to he likes to yip and Yap
sometimes but he's very comfortable in
the at ham Federal one Studios yeah in
his little Nook and he doesn't say a
thing because he's also a very sweet
quiet boy and he'll just hang out
forever he really is a good dog mrno
underscore Dave chill schweed says they
coat pennies and null pink so they don't
have to watch the inhuman act they
commit in eating them
they called pennies and milk you don't
have to watch themselves eat if you've
ever if you've ever these people fill a
coffee cup with pennies
I've seen it invisible pennies you ever
seen you ever gone to a one of these
blue cities you go to a you go to a
coffee place
and these people
they they they what they do is they go
into a coffee place and if you see them
what they'll do is they'll finish the
coffee and then uh a little while later
you'll see them pick up the cup but it's
empty no it's not it's filled with no
pink panties
like how close are we to something like
that I mean what Alex Jones says some of
that [ __ ] is crazy as [ __ ]
lonely lulio we come on now we're doing
the show here buddy he always likes to
be he doesn't like to be down below and
sitting on a bar stool
pink the the smell of burglary Sanders
says the smell of sulfur is palpable
from sangria sangria says
pink smells like nulfur
Milford sulfur but with null in front of
it
pink smells like nulfur no no pink gink
a link pink it's sulfur
what what dude it's so [ __ ] crazy
oh man so you're not watching any sports
or and you don't so you didn't even know
[ __ ] Aaron judge hit 62 home runs
breaking the American League record and
breaking Roger Marissa's record which
stood until the steroid era the only
guys who have broken it are like
you know very likely do to have done
massive massive amounts of steroids
is 62 home runs a lot of home runs
dude it was a record that stood since
1961 I think what about the uh what
about um
uh what's his face
um
in the early 2000s McGuire set Mark
McGuire I believe this was in 99 or
maybe 2000 it was McGuire and Sosa were
[ __ ] chasing it simultaneously but in
the National League they both broke it I
think Maguire got 73 and or he got 71 I
think and Sosa got 66 or something like
that then the next year Sosa broke it
again and got like 64 or something so he
broke it two years in a row and then a
couple years after that Barry Bonds I
think
got 73 and I think that's the the
overall record but again that was
National League nobody had ever done in
the American League
other than Roger Maris who was a Yankee
and then again
um Aaron judge so he broke it 62 is like
the new record and I guess it's believed
that he's not doing steroids now it's
like the story iters behind us that's
the identity War but I think it's just
like the companies who make that [ __ ]
have boiled it down to be able to like
you know they can take it right up to
the line of what the drug test can
detect
I got two questions for you but first uh
humble on Discord just shared an AI meme
of uh Alexandria ocasio-cortez eating
change no no no oh my God AOC eating
[ __ ] loose change that's [ __ ]
incredible
and then a picture of Sammy Sosa who
recently turned into a white man did you
notice this no yeah Sammy Sosa this is a
few years ago well perhaps he has
Vitiligo or something and I don't know
what's going on there but here are my
two questions
uh number one
um the maybe I only have one now because
I waited too long and I'm stoned let me
see if I know the other one oh yeah here
it is okay uh are the rules different in
the American League to the National
League that would change the amount of
home runs well
yeah they are that was a really at least
they used to be I don't know if they are
anymore because
sorry I'm interrupting I'm committing
the cardinal sin what is it the exact
opposite of an NPS no no pink silence
but as you thought about your answer you
did a little MPS brawler oh nice he said
no pink silence and it doesn't matter
how fast you played a podcast dude Chad
Colton you could play a podcast of five
times repeat if you want brother but
you'll never get in the way of The NPS
dude because when you're rolling with
The NPS brawler
you're with them
for Life dude and that's too sweet
because Hulk Hogan can't hit that high
register to give the two sweet dude not
like the blue meanie dude the blue bwo
because let me tell you something about
the bwo and the MPS dude when they join
hands what what's gonna happen is it the
ionosphere man is it the stratosphere
with The NPS and the bwo is one guiding
force we could go ahead and take the
whole WWF dude
so you know in Duty ball
um doozy ball is an offshoot of
dodgeball and baseball and running
around I guess and straight there's no
running in it and scraping toppings off
of pizza oh yeah you're right there's no
running around it's like a silly
stationary game
so maybe at some point in the future as
it is it's a stationary outdoor Indoor
Sport yeah as doozy ball goes over the
next you know 100 years we're going to
be around for I'll be around for at
least 53 of it of those years uh so that
I can reach 100 as per dudes these
orders do you think that dudesy ball
will split off and become two different
sports like or American League and
National League
I could see something like that or some
kind of regional differentiation
Rusty Shackleford says like January 6th
that would be oh that would be [ __ ]
well I mean if there's a major league
of of uh if there's a major league I
lost Rusty shackleford's comment if
there's a major league of doozy ball I
would imagine yeah I would imagine so
there's going to be
how many cities
you know what would be so great is
someday Duty ball there's only two
cities Souls yeah I don't know well see
where doozy takes it I'm curious I mean
I assume at some point we're gonna have
to fight each other or something
I can only assume that I mean a
two-team league
sure and they have to play like 500
games it's like six games a day for the
for six months yeah and it should be
like weird like just like like [ __ ]
Fort Lauderdale and Boise you get
drafted into the team you don't even
have a choice it's like jury duty
I lost that uh comment I was gonna read
let's see what's happening now though
um
blue league and orange League there it
is Bry Bry funny face who's provided
many uh funninesses to our Instagram and
Twitter says who League in Orange League
brother
oh Gibson says the rules are identical
now
national league has the DH now yeah that
used to be that was when I watched
baseball as a kid the American League
had a designated hitter and the national
league did not so pitchers had to hit so
National League was like
I guess kind of offensively didn't have
like the crazy [ __ ] that happened in the
late 80s with like Conseco Maguire on
the A's as the bash Brothers that kind
of like wacky [ __ ] but
I guess they're identical now and I know
at some point in the early 2000s or
mid-2000s maybe they started playing
each other in the regular season which
never used to happen oh I do remember
that being a Layman uh follower of
baseball and what I mean by that is I
never [ __ ] watch it I remember my
second question for you about Sosa and
McGuire well he would um would uh with
Sosa McGuire
would uh that would that have all gotten
asterisked from record because they were
so Juiced I don't know if they asked
just them or not
um
hey here's something I wanna I wanna I
wanna run past you yeah
um I already lost it because this is
going fast and these people are I don't
know who said it but someone said you
and me versus uh Bobby Lee and Andrew
Santino and dudesyball it was chief
engineer of sad chiming in again
[Music]
hear us make this dream a reality yeah
as as my good buddy Chow says my good
buddy ciao always says
let me know where they're gonna be let
me know when I gotta be there
um I didn't play baseball growing up but
for one season of [ __ ] you know
Little League Baseball yeah I played I
played a lot of football I played a lot
of soccer I played soccer into as a kid
into high school I was like can I please
just play football and only football I
hate soccer I scored one goal in eight
years but I was a center halfback is
that what it is I don't know dude it was
just so I could do the throw-ins on both
sides now here's the thing about
baseball I played for one year and our
coach who was great I actually brought
him up on the podcast recently because
at his home was the first time I saw
Hulk Hogan uh interesting I think unless
I happen to have catch him on TV before
that it was when he was uh
oh no maybe it was around the same time
as he started showing up um more on TV
but uh he was in Rocky 3 of course yeah
NPS
he was in Rocky 3 of course and um this
was this guy was a great guy this coach
he was great we'll call him uh Mr Tomas
Thomas Tomas
coach Tomas he was a great guy but one
day we were in a game and we used to use
the pitching machine and some drunk dad
uh cranked up the pitching machine to
whatever 90 or some [ __ ] and uh I was
The Catcher And he just lit me the [ __ ]
up and then I was just covered in
[ __ ] welts and bruises he put He was
firing baseballs at you as a catcher
like to teach you how to get one hops or
what no just during the game striking
kids out drinking a [ __ ] Molson
Jesus yeah it was [ __ ] awesome
um and also another silly [ __ ] up
thing from that year of baseball was
that uh coach Tomas went around and gave
everyone nicknames and they were all
terrible so he's like yeah you're you're
a speedy feet and you're uh you're Mr
you're Mr Big bats and just the Earth
yeah and you know what my nickname was
in Little League baseball
no
Mr T
what
my nickname in Little League Baseball
was Mr T he gave you this nickname for
what reason
he just said you know Mr T is tough and
you're a tough guy and you're you know
and perhaps it was after that [ __ ]
Sunday in the park when I got you know
beaned at a you know major league
pitcher level just taking taking 90 mile
per hour automated uh that's unreal AI
pitches from a [ __ ] pitching machine
so he called me Mr T and that's a dumb
nickname for a little white boy
yeah I agree but and I I mean little
only in age because I was a large little
boy yeah
um yeah that's a horrific season I
myself played baseball from age
four until probably 38.
yeah that's right you played you played
that men's league yeah dude I love that
men's league it was so fun Sunday games
and we'd play you know it was fast pitch
play at colleges there were like a
couple ex you know minor league guys or
college players every once so I would
come out as like a pitcher and just
throw 95 and just be like oh strike out
the entire team the whole game cool but
uh I still thought it was really fun to
have like some level of competition and
stuff
but then yeah dude you hit those late
30s and you start getting injured
brother and you're constantly just
having some [ __ ] nagging injury that
always hurts dudes or you got to give it
up brother and that's retirement dude oh
yeah you gotta decide what sports to
play is an adult yeah and it's real
simple yeah there's only one sport out
there yeah that's a stationary team
sport yeah that's Duty ball
only one stationary sport dig it
you can't be running around at 38
thinking that you're thinking thinking
that you're in high school you gonna
play Doogie ball you gotta do three
things you gotta screed the toppings off
the pizza and put it on salad you gotta
wrap that crust around
you gotta play Fuji boy yeah that's your
Sunday from now on straight Savage says
will still had to use the t-ball when he
was at bat hey
no I didn't you know that that was
that's the that's that's the thing
growing up in the 80s where there was no
participation you know or uh you know
Awards as they say these uh you know
back in the day when it was a different
time dude
different time dude I almost went yeah
yeah
back then let me tell you that they take
the kid that isn't very good you know to
play baseballs yeah and then they make
him hit from the table but then they
embarrass him yeah
I'm gonna have a little uh marijuana NPS
yeah dude my dad wouldn't let me play
t-ball he started me out at a pitching
machine when I was like four or whatever
in this [ __ ] League that he found you
know somewhere outside the town that did
that [ __ ] because he was like legit
serious like you're gonna be a pro
baseball player
he was he the dad that like would make
you do extra [ __ ] after a baseball game
or practice every one yeah
dude I had a friend who one of the one
of the dudes I grew up with
she [ __ ] his old man
is my buddy uh Thomas his old man would
make him run [ __ ] uh wind Sprints
after a game if he did some wrong [ __ ]
yeah and I will tell you this
I think I got as good as I could ever be
at baseball I think that definitely
happened unfortunately that was like
pretty good high school baseball player
you know that's it that's that's the
best I was ever gonna be and I think
through what he like all the drills and
all that [ __ ] I definitely hit my 100
mark it just wasn't
that remarkable
that's a nice NPS right there we haven't
had an NPS you're selling me on it
you're selling me on the silences now
I'm going to start listening to
everything at half speed
um uh
uh uh straight Savage says Jokes Aside
Chad that's awful I agree I know I wish
I could have [ __ ] at least played
college or something you know I played
one game in that League that I played in
the championship game one year was at
USC's baseball field and uh we won that
Championship that year
which was a cool experience that's where
I went to [ __ ] College
I had seen games there and then I got to
play on it that's like as close as I got
to some kind of experience like that I
think and that was when I was probably
34 35.
um
out of ammo out of ammo with uh three
O's says Pizza salad is just antipasto
salad changed my mind first of all
Auntie past like a real antipasto you
know just whatever just me you know
[ __ ] bring out the the cold cuts
bring up the soprasada you know okay
bring up the [ __ ] cachetori salami
you know what I'm saying sure uh um
and and um Calabrese and uh just throw
some [ __ ] cheese out there some buns
but Pizza salad is is way different
you know Chad you took you took uh doozy
ball
you took baseball rather as far as you
could right yeah but but lately so but
like Paul Triple H Levesque uh said on
this past week's Smackdown when just
when you think things are ending that's
really the beginning and I think
who better to take the dudes doozy ball
into
uh this Century as Pioneers but also
perhaps the Hank Aaron and Babe Ruth of
dudesy ball I think as you and me well I
think wait a minute let me tell you
something dude he's got us doing the
same smoke plan and I want to talk about
that and how I'm doing with that in a
moment
let me get a hit of marijuana so it's
challenging to remember to talk about
nice
um
um a little THC NPC there
um NPS THC and yes
um Locus says but how far can you go in
dudesy ball is the real question
that's right dude that's what's up we're
gonna get [ __ ] smoked a doozy bow it
doesn't matter
what yeah okay I see the point
hear it Duty make it happen and then we
each get we would each have to have a
third member
we have to get a [ __ ] ringer
yeah somebody's got a [ __ ] arm we're
looking for
an X D3 college quarterback Maybe
I'm picking up what you're laying down
Marshall
joint compound cook was a division three
quarterback let me tell you I throw the
[ __ ] ball around with Marshall uh you
know and he he [ __ ] Zips it in there
and it's like it's one of those things
where you're competing
um and if I may uh I learned how to
throw the ball
um when I was a kid because my buddy
Phil he wanted to be the quarterback and
he ended up becoming the quarterback and
uh you know like through the thing and
he went in he played at UBC for the
Thunderbirds University of British
Columbia and he uh
he he he wanted you know when we were
little kids he's like I'm gonna be a
quarterback so throw the ball with me
every [ __ ] day after school so I got
a pretty good arm just from that and it
turns into one of those competitions
where you're like oh yeah [ __ ]
sure Marshall can [ __ ] zip it in
there by the way I'd be remiss if I
didn't mention find D3 division three
football's finest it's a movie that
Marshall made a little over a decade ago
funniest football comedy
yeah
um and uh and that's the dude that's the
dude that we need Marsh we're gonna have
to suck up the [ __ ] Marsh now and get
him to be on our duty ball team but we
also have to start doing some
strategizing I mean is this gonna happen
we're saying this
whatever if it happens if it doesn't
let's play tell you what I'll tell you
what happens dude
uh-huh good things happen when it's just
two dudes zooming around yeah don't you
worry about the hit on the head we're
gonna put it right there and I'm gonna
shake your hand Hulk Hogan all right um
well we have to then start thinking
about is who would they be able to get
who would other podcasts get ah no who
would Bobby Lee
be able to Andrew Santino get yeah
because can we compete with that I feel
like they can get a [ __ ] Clayton
Kershaw or something yeah maybe they'll
get uh major league baseball pitch you
know what yeah who's this guy who just
those [ __ ] balls
those little balls I think they're gonna
be hard to throw for anyone I think
we'll be okay
um for any three-person uh three-person
Slash two guy podcast out there
we could probably compete with them you
know
um
we could do
who who what other
um whether there's plenty of podcasts
that have that have three so much in
this [ __ ] chat I don't even know
where to begin oh my god dude
will zazzo playing baseball
Speedo
um practicing dude uh principal screen
says I've been practicing doozy ball
every day for eight hours since it was
invented and I'm confident I'm the
number one player in the world currently
I was the best in the seventh grade I
was the best in the eighth grade and I'm
gonna be the best in the ninth grade
[ __ ]
um here's the thing I wanted to say
about the
doozy six-month plan
um I I I haven't been lifting weights
much I've been really [ __ ] busy and I
like to get to the gym in the morning
versus uh I do too same yeah and and so
um
the the
yeah so I want to admit here that it
hasn't been I haven't been keeping it
100 and that's no cap
you know
and but I wanted to explain that to me
um
uh I I I I need to I need
I need to get into better shape for a
lot of reasons and uh while
you know while I feel like well here's
what I want to say here's the bottom
line
some of you have been doing it out there
uh doing the doozy six-month plan and I
see some of the posts on doogee on
dude's Instagram
but uh I I really actually want to do it
and I want to connect somehow perhaps
it's here on Discord but really kicking
up a notch because I [ __ ] lifting
weights again reminded me that I liked
to lift weights yeah dude I've lifted
weights for for much of my you know
adult life and stuff and into my teams
and [ __ ] and I think it's really good
for you for a lot of [ __ ] reasons and
it's crucial to me losing weight when I
lost
when I hold on I got to get way more
stone for what I'm about to say but this
is what I thought I couldn't remember
to say earlier so I can afford to do
this
please
[Music]
and then